everyone has doubts sometimes you look
into the mirror and see this guy in a
suit and tie and you wonder is this
really me that's this work for me am i
overdoing it shouldn't I go back to
playing it more casual well the answer
is simple no look it's gonna take a
while for you to develop a sense of what
works for you and what doesn't it's a
process and that process actually never
really stops in the meantime while
you're feeling a little insecure you can
listen to others but whose judgment can
you trust good question let's start with
those you can't first of all do not
trust any man over the age of 35 who
still wears jeans and t-shirts and
thinks that's a suitable attire for work
not even if he's your best friend and
for these reasons do not trust the sales
guy in the store who tells you this suit
was made for you and as much as it pains
me to say this do not trust your mum I
know she loves you but she may want you
to look like a more depth version of
your dad at 25
who can you trust any man who style you
admire just ask we love giving advice do
trust your female colleagues at work
especially if they're over the age of 14
in their working lives they have seen so
many badly dressed men they appreciate
if you make an effort because they make
an effort every day listen to them and
you know what count yourself lucky if
you like me have an older sister or two
like mom they love you unconditionally
but their taste might be a bit more
current also they keep you from making a
fool out of yourself if only to protect
the family honor
[Music]